Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker:
Actors are a different beast,
they behave differently than everyone else on set.
It's like they're the popular kids in high school.
Film Courage: The first one was being able
to think on your feet you said and then the
second skill a good director should have
is just being very proficient with editing?
Jason: Yes, really understanding editing. I think
the third skill and this i'd say is number one and
it's knowing how to work with actors. I am
continually shocked at how that is a skill
that most directors don't seem to know.
I don't understand why that one is the
one that's shoved aside. Just today
a friend of mine who's a DP said that
they're working with an actor, the lead of this
movie, and the lead is not good. I said “Well
hopefully your director can direct the actor
and bring up a good performance?” She said
“No, the director's giving no notes whatsoever.
He's working with the camera department and the
actors left on their own.” The amount of time
is unbelievable the amount of times I hear
actors complain about this. I went out
there, I'm doing my thing, I'm getting
no notes. I have no idea what I'm doing. If
you understand what it's like to be an actor,
it's like painting blindfolded. You're
out there performing but you can't see it
and if your director is hiding
in video village back there
not telling you that it's a very frustrating place
to be as an actor and it just astounds me that
more directors don't spend more time learning the
skill and it seems to be this terror when it comes
this idea that working with an actor is scary.
I’m not sure where that idea comes from. I worked
with an actor or rather a director friend of mine
a couple years ago was helping her out on set
and I heard her say “Well this actor has worked
with Martin Scorsese, what do I have to say?”
I'm like “What do you mean? You're the director
they want to hear what you have to say! They
don't care that you are not Martin Scorsese
they just need to know what you want.” The most
common excuse I hear from directors when it
comes to this kind of subject is they always
say that oh well just cast the right person
and that will solve your problems well first
of all I think that's a terrible philosophy to
have because what that is saying is well I'm just
gonna make sure that I'm going to hire the right
person so that they can do the hard work that's
taking all of the pressure off of you and throwing
it on someone else so that you can just get out
of actually preparing and learning how to do it
second of all it's completely unrealistic
do how many projects there are when you're
working on something you were always going
to have the one person that you didn't cast
the the the I was working on a commercial one
time and I picked this act I thought this actor
was really good and they had this great presence
to them the client said no we want this other guy
and I was like I don't think this guy has
any experience I think he's kind of new and
in his audition he didn't even read the
lines they cast him because of his look
so he gets set so I have no choice this is
the guy I have to work with he shows up and
sure enough it was his first time on set all
right so now the philosophy of just cast the
right people suddenly that's gone and now what
are you gonna do well what are you gonna do so
I mean the amount of films that are
made where the investor says hey I'll
give you the money for your movie but
I'm gonna put my daughter in the lead
has your daughter ever acted well no but you got
a movie and you just have to make my daughter look
good okay so then how do you do it how do you work
with the actor oh oh no the actor they're so scary
actors are a different beast they behave
differently than everyone else on set
it's like they're like the
popular kids in high school
they're what I mean and you're the nerd the
dork sitting there at the lunch table and
whoever walks in and they're like they're charming
and everyone likes them and they're so pretty and
everyone just wants to be be them or be with them
that's the actors are like that that's why we
always point the cameras at them because they have
that charm and they have that look so it can feel
like you're the dork in high school who's got to
go up and now you're going to talk to this person
and tell them what to do and they're going to
listen why would they listen to me who am I so
that's the feeling often times that you can
get well the reality is they're a person
and oftentimes I find that especially when they
can be difficult to work with it's because they're
terrified they're they're just a person they
happen to be blessed with this beautiful outer
shell a lot of the time but that doesn't mean
they don't have insecurities as well and the more
they're left on their own without any direction
the more insecure they can feel I mean think about
what that must be like if you you go out there and
you do your scene and no one says anything to you
and you have just bared your soul in some
scene and no one's going good job or whatever
like that that that might even frustrate you
make you angry well with good reason right
I mean it's like working for any boss and the
boss is never telling you if you're doing good
work never encouraging you never to I mean
it would be very frustrating place to be so
understanding that they are just a human and
it's so funny because I oftentimes I'll come up
actor will come up on on set I'll walk up to
them and I can see them trembling like if I'm
and it's weird because I'll be at my director's
chair and talking to the DP and we're doing
this over here da da and I look and there's the
actor and they come in and oh they're pretty and
and I walk up and I see him kind
of shaking it's like wow I never
saw that until I actually walked
up and made that connection so
the lesson there is I think really making sure
that they're recognized and that they are welcomed
and feel safe that is so important to do to
because what we're asking of an actor think
about this in the in the grand scheme of a set
if you're a cinematographer they're not they are
operating a piece of machinery they're
bringing their artistry to it no question
they're creating emotion with this camera painting
with light but they're not being vulnerable they
may be even if they are scared you're never
going to see it because they're behind the lens
same with the gaffer same with a sound guy and a
wardrobe person they I mean if they're having a
bad day they could go and cry in their trailer
behind closed doors you never can see that an
actor they're they're naked in front of the
and everything that you've been building
for years with the script and everything is
pointing at them the camera is pointing right
that's a lot of stress on a person so when you see
them walk in you're in high school a popular kid
walks in it can be the hardest thing to do to walk
up and just say hey how you doing everything okay
just check in and make sure they're all
right that is a huge move and that will be
think about it making them feel welcome and
comfortable even though it looks like they
may not need that do it anyway that
is a huge thing that will help you
actors as well simply and it sounds so simple
to say but they just want to know what you want
if you don't know what you want tell them
because this is where you can invite them into
your own space in storytelling you can say
this is a goodbye scene but I'm not sure it
needs to be a weepy one and have a dialogue
with them about it because that's where the
fun can begin where you're actually going
you're saying goodbye to someone who you've been
best friends with for years but they've always
been mean to you would you really be crying as
you say like what and you can start to play well
what if it's triumphant goodbye what if it's
and that's where it could be really fun now
you're going to start to see the actor come
alive because they are being allowed to
play with you and you're on the same team that
can really be a lot of fun I also think that
as a director what we do because because we've
been thinking about this story for longer than
anybody else on the team like they're longer
than the DP the wardrobe person we've been
in working with this story forever and so it's
very easy to and necessary in a lot of ways
to come in with your own ideas about how the
scene should look and yes that's important but
you want to leave a little room for surprise you
want to leave a little room for them to bring what
they have to the table and you would do that you
do that in every other department right you you're
you're going to tell the DP I just want this to
look like like the whole films from the 70s how
they kind of had this rich color grain kind
of looking for that kind of rich color grain
in this kind of thing and I'm thinking
it's all shot on long lenses and the DP
may go yeah but in that time those kind of
lenses didn't exist they did a lot of zooms
instead of dollies so what if we did it more zoomy
lenses oh yeah that's right that's right how cool
is that that's you creating together that's you
allowing the DP to kind of bring his artistry or
her artistry to the table do the same with an
actor I find it really enjoyable process when
they come to set they've been working their
lines by themselves or with their husband or wife
or or sometimes even just a recorder they're they
record it they have a certain way they want to do
the lines well let them try it I think it's it
can really create the fun sandbox when you're
you bring the two or three actors and have
everyone pause the work let the DP sit over
here for a second and say all right let's just
walk through it a second see what's what you got
let me see what you got let's just let's try it
boom walk through the scene now they feel like
they've brought something to the table you're
able to like okay that's cool let's use this
piece but I think what we want to do is turn
in this moment here and then oh yeah yeah
now you're working together that really
allows them a feeling like they've been heard
and that will just you could just you
can watch their anxiety just go down
another big thing to remember with actors
is that when you're directing this is super
easy to do because you're being hit with a
thousand questions a minute so I mean it is
you just did a take the DP’s like are you sure
it's okay with this lens like this like I think
maybe we go to a tighter lens oh yeah okay good
let's swap to the hundred and do the blah blah
wardrobe person's like I don't know this shirt
looks kind of wrinkly and oh yeah cool is that
background prop looking okay and everyone's asking
and the actor is standing there on their mark
like is that all right like and you're all right
let's do it again you totally forget that they're
out there naked wondering why we're doing it again
and it has nothing to do with them so remembering
all right we need to do one more we got to
make a change on our end you're doing just
fine just keep doing that exactly thing you're
right in the right zone but we got to change
something with the camera we've hit a
bobble on the cable whatever it is like
remembering that it's like you're spinning plates
on the end of sticks and the actors always on the
end out here and you'd think that they'd be
the easiest one to remember but that's the
first one usually most people forget is that
they're just standing out there on their mark
waiting for someone to talk to so just remembering
to keep them engaged I haven't forgotten about
you you're still there it's all good let's
fix something over here or whatever I think
yeah that that happened number of times
on the abandoned by the way where it was
the abandon is essentially one actor
in front of the camera the whole time
and a lot of these same rules applied right so
the the premise of the abandon is a soldier who's
hit with a bright light when he's in the middle of
a firefight and he wakes up in this room with no
doors windows exits of any kind
he can't get a hold of anybody
and the whole movie is him trying to escape
this mystery room well that means he's in the
only guy in front of the camera the whole time
that's an incredible vulnerable place to be
the the actor that is like it
was his first lead in a movie
and that's that's that's terrifying I don't
I wouldn't want that position like if I were
a lead in a film that's scary enough but the fact
that you're the only face we're gonna see in this
whole movie oh my gosh it was so important
to take the time to make sure he was okay
just greet him every day on set see check in see
how he was feeling making sure he's comfortable
go through it let him try a couple takes to see
what he all of these same kinds of things then
with him specifically there were a couple times
where we would have some bumps in the road and
this this leads me to a huge point I made a couple
mistakes there was a day where we were doing some
stunt sequences and and ironically the
moment I'm talking about is in the trailer
there's a moment where the character realizes that
something is very wrong oh no the big discovery is
being made and he goes oh my goodness we were
trying to do this very specific shot where the
camera was going to do this big dolly push and
it's tilting as it goes and he's leaning on the
wall a certain kind of way and I'm and the way the
film is put together we had this camera that could
do this it's called a lambda head so we could
tilt it and and the film plays with gravity a
lot so we would always tilt the lambda head
oftentimes to make it look like gravity was
coming from the wrong direction but when you
look at the lens and then you look at the stage
it looks ridiculous because the he's oftentimes
standing at a tilt and it's like I would start
chuckling because it's like I feel like I'm
making star trek in 1960 because it's just like
people throwing themselves around so I'm just
like kind of chuckling at the hilarity of it all
and I'm trying to get this very real moment
for him the cinematographer wasn't feeling
well that day and I'm trying to get this shot
we were all this is like three quarters of the
way through the shoot we're all completely
exhausted and I'm giggling at the monitor
well here's the actor all he knows is that
people are looking at him on screen and laughing
right so understandably so he was feeling
extremely insecure and got mad at me it's a dude
I feel like my ass is hanging in the wind out here
and I and I he said I think you're laughing at me
and I realize in that moment that of course he
would feel that way of course he would think that
he has no idea the context of where I'm coming
from but the poor guy is understandably frustrated
with me so the point I'm trying to make is these
things are gonna happen miscommunications happen
you're gonna snap sometimes you're gonna say
something that you didn't mean that's gonna
hurt somebody's feelings and it's so
important to own up to it to after that day
I actually had to we had he and I had
a long long talk about like hey man
I never meant to humiliate you that is was never
my intent and I did not mean for it to come out I
was laughing at something totally different
just the comical nature of what we do for a
living was really more of what I was thought was
so funny at the time it was nothing to do with
how stupid you looked no I would never laugh at
something like that like I'm here to protect you
but I had to come forward it was very difficult
I had to tell him and be very honest and
really protect him in that moment this happens
a lot if you find that you snapped at your
actors some way because they irritated you and
you did it in front of everybody it's a good
idea to pull them aside after that or the next
day or whatever and say hey that was out of line
what that's going to do is that's going to do this
you're going to be as vulnerable as they're
we're asking them to be and it's going to put
you on this even level with them where you're
both hey we're human we're trying to do this
thing there's a lot of pressure the sun is going
down we're running out of time I snapped I'm
sorry can we get past this and just I'll try to
do better next time that's such a big really I
think important move to do to be willing to do
that that'll help you with actors quite a bit
usually if you are that vulnerable with them their
performance will go up because they know that it's
safe they know that you're all working together
trying to do the same kind of thing and they
once they are vulnerable vulnerability with an
actor is the secret sauce to good performance
because that is what this is why this what makes
them different this is what when you see Denzel
Washington performing what you're seeing
that's so incredible is he's so open he's
you are seeing the inner workings the
inner terror the little soul in there
that's what's so interesting that's what makes
us all lean into the screen that's that's what
draws us in it's these it's these while people who
behave like that generally become actors who are
used to exposing themselves like that that that's
not normal that's not what normal humans do that's
what makes them so interesting to watch that's
what we need but in order to see that you have
to make them feel safe feel comfortable they want
to see vulnerability in you it's a relationship.
Are you afraid of working with actors?